mark is with us in Washington hi mark
how are you
great thanks taking my call sure what's
up I'm looking after some advice and
when to cut loose my term life insurance
policy divorced five years ago remarried
nagas I've got some kids a little ways
out from graduating high school one two
and a half years away one four and a
half years away and try to figure out
how all that fits into things so just
looking for some advice well so your
dependents are teenage children and
you're entering your new wife yep and
how much do you have in investments I've
got almost 900 in 401k and mutual funds
and I've got half my house paid off okay
what's your house worth 900 ok so you
owe 450 still and what's your household
income 800 ok 800,000 800,000 I'd pay a
hundred and seventy seven in child
support and spousal annually what do you
do for a living
I'm an executive Wow good for Harold all
over there yeah you're moved up you have
done well regulations yeah okay well I
mean with the kind of money you make the
point is what who's going to take care
of your having is 900 K enough to take
care of your spouse this mortgage and
your kids no no it's not so you're not
self-insured you know that the bottom
line is I mean if it creates $100,000
your income and they're used to
receiving a hundred and seventy seven
over there now you wouldn't be
necessarily that concerned about your
former spouses support but you would be
about your kids correct yeah and
probably the smaller portion of that 177
is child support because usually child
supports not that high so but what would
you want to have as a string
of income to your kids and as a stream
of income to your spouse your current
spouse correct
how much oh man the kids all in or 98
thousand right now you think that
Sundaram nope no I got 150 a Chinese
including my net worth I've got 150
saved in college so you know I guess if
I look at it combined between the two
kids that is seven years I've got to
cover them all in so I'm talking about
I'm talking about annual cash flow how
much do they need today Matt today right
now is Meghan okay the year we'll call
it a hundred and how much annual cash
flow would your spouts current spouse
need if you died today
gets the out statement that's 3,500 but
I'm planning on having that house paid
off in September 2023 all right gotta go
soon or not with the income you got a
nice trip are you my guess is what I
need probably 150 I mean I'm wearing
that all right so let's just let's call
it let's call it quarter-million dollars
a year
all right as it supports both of them
and you need to get that house paid off
quicker and that you make eight hundred
but let's get the you know for today you
need a quarter million dollars coming to
them so you just simply multiply that by
ten or twelve so you need two and a half
three million dollars to create invested
a an income thrown off of a couple of
hundred thousand right yep and you've
got a million of it so you need to meet
you know life insurance today now when
you get to a net when you get to a point
that three million dollars is there then
you would not need life insurance or
when the kids are grown which might
happen before you get to that point
because they're older I mean when
they're when they're off the payroll so
to speak and they're on their own if you
die and you're not gonna be you're not
to leave an income to a 25 year old you
know no way okay and so we're gonna get
them you and you've got College set
aside for them you said so if you got
College covered so
when they graduate from high school you
probably have just about exhausted your
need to take care of them monthly right
okay so that's you know that that's the
kind of stuff you know bottom line is do
you have enough assets to supply the
needs and you don't right now even
though these numbers are ridiculously
large in all cases congratulations